that's great that's terrific
wow i gotta tell you conan i'm not too
thrilled about going on after bruce
springsteen
it's a spot i wouldn't give to a leopard
if anyone if anyone can handle what you
can well you're very nice to say so
thank you uh how long have you been
doing this you've been singing since
i've been singing now wait for it folks
fast and seat belts i've been singing
professionally since i was four years
old right
four years old
and uh
you started out actually you were a
drummer first right well i played drums
since i was about seven or eight years
old especially right
and then uh you switched you became a
singer no actually i did sing first i
sang with the old [ __ ] sanders band
at the blackhawk restaurant in chicago
when i was four right and that was the
beginning of my career
and uh and then you were in chicago and
you came did you dream about one day
coming to new york was that yeah i
always wanted to be a new york singer
you know i used to listen to the radio
in chicago and i would hear the tinkling
of glasses in the various venues i would
hear people laughing
imagining new york the sophistication of
new york and i always wanted to come
here and kind of own this town
that's correct and god has been very
good to me you've described yourself as
uh you know the happiest man alive i've
absolutely i really am
i'm the happiest guy alive
and uh
when you
when you hit it when you hit it big uh
you had a lot of nicknames of course
because the most common one i know you
were you're sick of it but it was you
were commonly known as the
velvet fog but you had some other ones
too which i didn't know about which were
yeah these were really
wonderful
one was mr butterscotch
you're ready for that uh here's the
here's the goodie there's a disc jockey
named fred robbins in town who's very
popular during the 30s and the 40s and
the 50s
and he tagged me not only with the
velvet fog but
wait for it
the kid with the gauze in his jaws
i want that
you got it all right all right from now
on that is how i will be known on this
show love it love it uh now one thing
that that uh i don't know if people
realize but you co-wrote uh one of the
most famous christmas songs
uh was the christmas song really for a
lot of people well you know a lot of
people don't identify
the christmas song when when i do an
interview and somebody says well tell me
what you've written i said well i wrote
the christmas song and they go
uh-huh what else have you written
and i always have to go
chestnuts roasting on an open
now a song like that a song like that
just uh
i mean that's that will be around
forever that will be around long after
all of us are gone that song will be out
there people will be singing it and it's
just fascinating how does something like
that happen how does something like that
get created well uh funnily enough i was
writing with a guy by the name of bob
wells we were a songwriting team
and what happened was i went out to his
house one day there was a spiral pad on
his piano with the first four lines of
that song written in pencil chestnuts
roasting on open fire jack frost nipping
at your nose etc so when he came into
view i said bob what's this he said
listen i am so hot today i jumped in the
pool i've done everything to cool off i
can't cool off so i wrote those lines as
an experiment to see if just looking at
them and thinking about them would cool
me off i looked at him and said
this
may be a song and in 40 minutes that
song was written that's amazing it's
great
[Applause]